18 hours ago Sam Altman put out this
simple tweet that you can now disable
chat history and training in chatty PT
and that we will offer charity business
in the coming months but dig a little
deeper and behind this tweet is a data
controversy that could engulf open AI
jeopardize GPT 5 and shape the new
information economy I will show you how
you can benefit from this new feature
reveal how you can check if your
personal info was likely used in Gypsy 4
training and investigate whether chanti
BT could be banned in the EU Brazil
California and Beyond but first the
announcement openai say that you can now
turn off chat history in chat TPT but
that is only conversations that were
started after chat history is disabled
that won't be used to train and improve
their models meaning that by default
your existing conversations will still
be used to train their new models so how
does it work and what does this mean
what you need to do is click on the
three dots at the bottom left of a chat
GPT conversation then go to settings and
show and here's where it starts to get
interesting they have linked together
chat history and training it's both or
neither they could have given two
separate options one to store your chat
history so that you can look back over
it later and another to opt out of
training but instead is one button you
either give them your data and keep your
chats or you don't give them your data
and you don't keep your chats if you opt
not to give them your chat history they
still monitor the chats for what they
call abuse so bear that in mind what if
I want to keep my history on but disable
model training we are working on a new
offering called chat GPT business I'm
going to talk about that in a moment but
clearly they don't want to make it easy
to opt out of giving over your training
data now In fairness they do offer an
opt-out form but if you go to the form
it says cryptically please know that in
some cases this will limit the ability
of our models to better address your
specific use case so that's one big
downside to this new announcement well
what's one secret upside this export
data button buried all the way down here
if you click it you quite quickly get
this email which contains a link to
download a data export of all your
conversations after you download the
file and open it you now have an easy
way to search through all your previous
conversations literally all of them from
the time you first started using chat WT
to the present day that is a pretty
great feature I must admit but going
back to the announcement they said that
you need to upgrade to chatbt business
available in the coming months to ensure
that your data won't be used to train
our models by default but why these
announcements now why did Sam Altman
tweet this just yesterday well this
article also from yesterday in the MIT
technology review by Melissa iquila may
explain why it said that open AI has
until the end of this week to comply
with Europe's strict data protection
regime the gdpr but the that it will
likely be impossible for the company to
comply because of the way data for AI is
collected before you leave and say this
is just about Europe no it's much bigger
than that the European data collection
supervisor said that the definition of
Hell might be coming for open AI based
on the potentially illegal way it
collected data if openai cannot convince
the authorities its data use practices
are legal it could be banned not only in
specific countries like Italy or the
entire EU it could also face Hefty fines
and might even be forced to delete
models and the data used to train them
these Stakes could not be higher for
open AI the eu's gdpr is the world's
strictest data protection regime and it
has been copied widely around the world
Regulators everywhere from Brazil to
California will be paying close
attention to what happens next and the
outcome could fundamentally change the
way AI companies go about collecting
data aside from your attractivity
conversations how do these companies
collect your day later while two
articles published this week tell us
much more to take one example they
harvest pirated eBooks from the site
formerly known as book ZZ until that was
seized by the FBI last year despite that
contents of the site remain in the
common crawl database openai won't
reveal the data set used to train GT4
but we know the common crawl was used to
train gpt3 openai may have also used the
pile which was used recently by
stability AI for their new llm stable LM
the pile contains more pirated ebooks
but also things like every internal
email sent by Enron and if you think
that's strange wait until you hear about
the copyright takedown policy of the
group that maintains the pile I can't
even read it out for the video this
article from The Washington Post reveals
even more about the data that was likely
used to train gbc4 for starters we have
the exclusive content of patreon so
presumably all my patreon messages will
be used to train Gypsy 5. but further
down in the article we have this search
bar where you can look into whether your
own website was used in the common crawl
data set I even found my mum's WordPress
family blog so it's possible that GT5
will remember more about my childhood
than I do if you think that's kind of
strange wait until you hear the open AI
themselves might not even know what's in
their training set this comes from the
gpt4 technical report and in one of the
footnotes it says that portions of this
big bench Benchmark were inadvertently
mixed into the training set that word
inadvertently is rather startling for
the moment let's not worry about how
mixing in benchmarks might somewhat
obscure our ability to test gpt4 let's
just focus on that word inadvertently do
they really not know entirely what's in
their data set whether they do or not I
want you to get ready to count the
number of ways that open AI May soon
have to pay for the data it once got for
free first read it they trolled Reddit
for all posts that got three or more
upvotes and included them in the
training data now this New York Times
article says Reddit wants them to pay
for the privilege the founder and chief
executive of Reddit said that the Reddit
Corpus of data is really valuable but we
don't need to give all of that value to
some of the largest companies in the
world for free I agree but my question
is will the users be paid in fact that's
my question for all of the examples you
have seen in this video and are about to
see does the user actually get paid if
openai is set to make trillions of
dollars as Sam Altman has said will you
get paid for helping to train it
apparently Reddit is right now
negotiating fees with openai but will
its users get any of that money what
about the Wikipedia editors that spend
thousands of hours to make sure the
article is accurate and then GPT 4 or 5
just trolls all of that for free what
about stack Overflow the Q a site for
programmers apparently they are now
going to also charge AI Giants for
training data the CEO said that users
own the content that they post on stack
Overflow under the Creative Commons
license but that that license requires
anyone later using the data to mention
where it came from but of course GT4
doesn't mention where its programming
tricks come from is it me or is there
not some irony in the people being
generous enough to give out answers to
questions in programming actually
training a model that may end up one day
replacing them all the while giving them
no credit or compensation but now we
must turn to lawsuits because there are
plenty of people getting ready to take
this to court Microsoft GitHub and
openai were recently sued with the
companies accused of scraping license
code to build github's AI powered
co-pilot tool and in an interesting
response Microsoft and GitHub said that
the complaint has certain defects
including a lack of injury and the
companies argue that the plaintiffs rely
on a hypothetical events to make their
claim and say that they don't describe
how they were personally harmed by the
tool that could be the big Benchmark
where these lawsuits fail currently
because no one can prove harm from GT4
but how does that Bode for the future
when some people inevitably get laid off
because they're simply not needed
anymore because Gypsy 4 or g65 can do
their jobs then would these lawsuits
succeed when you can prove that you've
lost a job because of a specific tool
which was trained using in part your own
data then there is injury there that you
could prove but then if you block Gypsy
4 or Gypsy 5 there will be millions of
coders who can then say that they're
injured because their favorite tool has
now been lost I have no idea how that's
going to pan out in the courts of course
these are not the only lawsuits with the
CEO of Twitter weighing in accusing
openai of illegally using Twitter data
and what about Publishers journalists
and newspapers whose work might not be
read as much because people can get
their answers from gpc4 and don't forget
their websites were also called to train
the models well the CEO of News Corp
said that clearly they are using
proprietary content there should be
obviously some compensation for that so
it seems like there are lawsuits coming
in from every direction but Sam Altman
has said in the past we're willing to
pay a lot for very high quality data in
certain domains such as science all that
actually in which scientists and
mathematicians or will it just add to
the profits of the massive scientific
Publishers that's another Scandal for
another video but I am wondering if
openai will be tempted to use some
illicit sites instead such as skyhub a
shadow Library website that provides
free access to millions of research
papers without regard to copyright it
basically gets past the scientific
Publisher's paywall and apparently up to
50 of academics say that they use
websites like skyhub inevitably Gypsy 5
is going to break through some news
science benchmarks I just wish that the
scientists whose work went into training
it were compensated for helping it do so
just in case it seems like I'm picking
on open AI Google are just as secretive
and they were even Accused by their own
employees of training Bard with chat GPT
data they have strenuously denied this
but it didn't stop Sam Altman from
saying I'm not that annoyed at Google
for training on chat GPT output but the
spin is annoying he obviously doesn't
believe their denial and given all of
this discussion on copyright and
scraping data I found this headline
supremely ironic openai are trying to
trademark the name GPT meaning all of
those models that you've heard of Auto
GPT memory GPT hugging GPT they might be
stopped from using that name imagine a
world where they win all of their
battles in court and they can use
everyone's data but no one can use their
name GPT but maybe this entire data
issue won't be relevant for much longer
Sam Altman recently said that he
predicts open AI data spend will go down
as models get smarter I wonder if he
means that the models might be able to
train their own synthetic data sets and
therefore not require as much outside
data or of course he could be talking
about simplifying the reinforcement
learning with human feedback phase where
essentially the model gives itself
feedback reducing the need for human
evaluators wouldn't that be quite
something if GT4 can generate a data set
that is used to train Gypsy 5. as
someone who uses gpt4 a lot and whose
data was used to train GPT models I
fluctuate between being amazed annoyed
and deeply concerned about where all of
this is going let me know in the
comments what you think of it all and
have a wonderful day